[Music]
how many times can you fold a piece of
paper assume that one had a piece of
paper that was very fine like the kind
they typically used to print the Bible
in reality it seems like a piece of silk
to clarify these ideas let's say you
have a paper that's one thousandth of a
centimeter in thickness that is 10 to
the power of minus 3 centimeters which
equals point 0 0 1 centimeters let's
also assume that you have a big piece of
paper like a page out of the newspaper
now we begin to fold it in half how many
times do you think it could be folded
like that and another question if you
could fold the paper over and over as
many times as you wish say 30 times what
would you imagine the thickness of the
paper would be then before you move on I
encourage you to actually think about a
possible answer to this question okay
after we have folded the paper once it
is now to thousands of a centimeter in
thickness if we fold it in half once
again the paper will become for
thousands of a centimeter with every
fold we make the paper doubles in
thickness and if we continue to fold it
again and again always in half we would
confront the following situation after
10 fold 2 to the power of 10 meaning
that you multiply 2 by itself 10 times
is 1024 thousands of a centimeter which
is a little bit over one centimeter
assume we continue folding the paper in
half what would happen then if we fold
it 17 times we'll get a thickness of 2
to the power of 17 which is 131
centimeters and that equals just over 4
feet if we were able to fold it 25 times
then we would get 2 to the power 25
which is 30 3554 centimeters just over
1,100 feet that would make it almost a
straw
as the Empire State Building it's
worthwhile to stop here and reflect for
a moment folding a paper in half even a
paper as fine as that of the Bible
twenty-five times would give us a paper
almost a quarter of a mile what do we
learn this type of growth is called
exponential growth and as you see just
by folding a paper we can go very far
but very fast to summarizing if we fold
the paper 25 times the thickness is
almost a quarter of a mile 30 times the
thickness reaches six point five miles
which is about the average height that
planes fly 40 times the thickness is
nearly seven thousand miles or the
average GPS satellites orbit 48 times
the thickness is way over 1 million
miles now if you think that the distance
between the earth and the moon is less
than 250,000 miles then standing with a
piece of Bible paper and folding it 45
times we get to the moon and if we
double it one more time we get back to
earth
you